there is one week left early voting
in the general election and local groups
are encouraging communities to send in
their ballots eight news now reporter
kate houston
live outside the loyd george courthouse
where a rally is expected to happen to
encourage latina women to vote hey kate
yes hey me familia vota is bringing
latino women together from all across
the community
to encourage them to vote now this rally
is just getting started
as you can see behind me we have a group
gathering here they've set up a mic
some candles people are holding white
roses ready to kick off this rally
me familia vota says research shows that
latino women are less likely to feel
excited and empowered to
vote by mail the group is encouraging
latino voters to send their ballot
through the mail
due to safety concerns over kovit 19 and
because it can be more accessible for
those who are working
according to pew research center there
are a record 32 million
latinos projected to be eligible to vote
in this election
that's going to account for more than 13
percent of all eligible voters
we definitely want to empower them i
mean you know
latinx folks are going to be the biggest
voting block in this election and we
want to make sure that that stays true
even through the pandemic even through
everything that's happening
tonight's rally will feature guests such
as councilwoman olivia diaz
assemblywoman selena torres and
immigrant justice corps fellow
paloma guerrero now the group is
expected to rally outside the courthouse
until 7 p.m tonight now back out here
live me familia votas expecting around
80 people to attend the rally
so far here we see just over 30 so they
are waiting for more members to show up
and of course they will be also handing
out any sort of ppe
if anybody needs that as well reporting
live from the lord george courthouse
kate houston 8 news now